in the pitch video for tiger within you
say that you've always been drawn to
characters that are
uh misfits outsiders rebels what is it
about
those type of characters don't we want
to root for the prom queen
well i think you know i think damaged
characters who are outsiders
first of all i think there's always a
touch of them in all of us you know i
think we're all
that you know but they are like the
gateway to
for us to enter a story and
you know in a way where through them
they experience so much more
than than we do but we do that too but
we
but you know by by having it i'm making
a total mess of this
you know um i i think we all are
deep inside our rebels you know but
sometimes
life doesn't allow us to to
you know be that you know we have to
conform we have to
you know be part of society we have to
make money we have to make a living you
know
but we would love to be free we would
love to explore we would love to turn
things upside down we all would love
that and as teenagers we all
are that you know and by you know
working with characters like that you
know
who probably in real life you know are
very not people who really would like we
would like to be because the pa
into journeys are full of pain but we
recognize our own struggles
the prom queen you i mean i do
i'm always like wow what would that be
like like uh you know i don't know what
that would be like
and i don't think many artists do
because they
are they're commenting on
what they feel whereas the
the prom queen is and people of that ilk
i don't mean just prom queens but
they're
they're um they're not that i i mean it
is a generalization but
they're they're i
think so protected from feelings by
adulation
whereas other people you know that are
shoved out they don't have that veneer
of protection
and they you know they they look at what
they
perceive and who knows what's going on
in her life
or his you know the quarterback or
whatever you just
when you know when people are clapping
for you all the time
um you're bowing you're not sitting
there thinking
you know and see that's why she's a
great writer
you know a writer can put it together
that's clinical language
for me i'm like groping for words you
know and i think
or i've thought about it a lot i mean
you know
i always wonder like i remember the last
picture show remember that movie
great movie you know in civil shepherd
it's like
she was just so perfect looking you know
and
i mean i was a kid when i saw you know
and she just was like oh my god like to
look like that and be that and she was
portrayed like that i mean it was a
brilliant movie
and many many many years later you know
when i'm an adult and doing tv
you know i meet sybil and she's a woman
and
you know and she's no longer the prom
queen and she's complex and
she's got a lot of layers that
didn't have an opportunity to emerge
then you know
or to be i shouldn't say emerge because
maybe they did
we don't know but they were invisible
you know
because her beauty and the protection
of the features and everything
everybody's staring at her and so she's
not you know the beautiful people they
there is a curse
there you know there um everybody is
is looking at them as a separate species
and i don't know that they um
the very i haven't met that many you
know celebrities that are like
traditionally beautiful but the ones i
have
have talked when again they could just
be bullshitting but they've said it's
very lonely
i don't know you know um but we imagine
what it is to be idolized like that
what i'm saying is that she is able to
put it in such a very precise beautiful
language
i am constantly struggling and i think
that's why when i'm on the set with
actors i throw so many colors at them
and cut
i guess get them confused so much that
they gave great performances because
they're so
so confused that they see so many colors
to
to you know that somehow it creates this
sense of life
a real life you know and i think if you
in when you're directing if you
sometimes tell an actor too precisely
you know
exactly the the process the emotion the
the intellectual thing behind it the
performance is sort of like killed it
becomes very dry so it works for us
she as a writer can put it in such
beautiful language and
i don't know how to do it but
it seems to work with actors
you